le mouvement de la place Maiden avait
commencé en novembre 2013 des
manifestants c'était rassemblés sur
cette place centrale de Kiev pour
protester contre la décision du
président Victoria nukovic de ne pas
signer un accord d'échange économiques
avec l'Union européenne
il avait plutôt le regard tourné vers
l'est vers la Russie
les rangs des manifestants ont gonflé
jusqu'à la violente réaction des forces
de l'ordre
entre le 18 et le 20 février 2014 107
personnes ont été tuées dans la
répression alors que Victoria nukovic
abandonné le pouvoir et prenait la fuite
avec les quelques 150000 soldats russes
massés aux frontières de l'Ukraine mais
cérémonie commémoration cette année
revêtent une dimension toute
particulière même la messe à la mémoire
des disparus n'a pas échappé aux propos
politiques
mais pas nous qui attaquons nous sommes
tolérants mais nous allons protéger nos
terres s'il le faut leur a dit le prêtre
dans son serment on le doit bien à ceux
qui ne sont plus là dis Antonina
cette liberté est un noble dit-elle en
mettant un dictateur à la porte avec la
révolution nous nous sommes donné
l'opportunité de construire un pays
démocratique et indépendant
d'autres commémorations auront lieu ce
dimanche jour officiel de mémoire à la
centaine céleste en reconnaissance de
leur sacrifice ultime l'Ukraine a aussi
instauré l'ordre de la centaine céleste
un honneur consenti à ceux qui
démontrent du courage du patriotisme qui
défendent les principes de la démocratie
et de la liberté
ici Marie-Ève Bédard Radio-Canada Kiev